hi it's Ria today I'm going to show you
my favorite hack I'm going to make
almond extract using cherries this is a
special device called Cherry Peter if
you don't have cherry Peter you can use
sturdy straw like it can be metal it can
be glass so this is pound walls of
cherry pits put them in a baking fridge
spread them out roast this at 400 degree
oven about 10 minutes and I'm going to
add my cherry pick I added vodka into
airtight photo and Shake It
you are going to keep this in a dark
warm place for three months and it look
like this next time you're making cherry
pies don't throw away your pits almond
extract is good for cookies cakes for
pies very fancy